[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and today we're going
to be talking about venom two because
Tom Hardy is at it again doing his usual
posting a photo and then instantly
deleting it Tom Hardy has been known to
do this on his Instagram especially when
it comes to venom - previously he has
posted things from the sect of venom -
and then instantly deleted it but of
course everybody who has notifications
on takes screenshots and we actually see
the post and of course Tom Hardy knows
that people do this that's why he only
keeps the post up for about a minute
because he knows everybody's going to
see it anyways but this is his fun
little way of teasing us and recently he
keeps teasing us that spider-man could
be in venom too so let's break down his
new post if he knew be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on all things
relating to venom 2 also so you can
enter my weekly giveaway for a chance to
win an Iron Man exclusive Funko pop all
you have to do is subscribe but like the
video and leave a comment down below
about the video to enter so about two
weeks ago some of you may have caught a
photo that Tom Hardy posted and then
deleted it was a venom basically biting
spider-man in half it was a pretty
brutal photo at least we thought it was
a brutal photo until he posted a new one
now this photo is by ultra raw 26 you
can find him on Instagram but Tom Hardy
shared his photo on his Instagram and
this photo is a venom basically biting
the head off of spider-man now I don't
think we'll ever truly see this
obviously they're not going to kill off
spider-man and venom - but Tom Hardy
does keep teasing spider-man and it's
interesting that this comes along with
the recent news of Sony's new name for
their spider-man universe if you missed
the news about this the official
spider-man fire from home page on
Twitter tweeted joined spider-man and
all his friends while you swing through
all the films from the spider-man
universe of characters not exactly the
best name but unfortunately that wasn't
the true name that Sony dubbed it the
actual name for the universe according
to IGN who reached out to Sony is Sony
Pictures at universe of Marvel
characters
but Sony is making a very specific
statement here by including Marvel in
the title they want everybody to know
that spider-man is a part of their
universe
this is also why they put vulture in the
Morbius trailer because the universes
are shared so of course the big question
now is is spider-man Tom Hollands
spider-man going to appear in venom 2
Tom Hardy has now teased it a couple of
times and Sony has now officially
changed their name so more people
associate their universe with the Marvel
Universe so it definitely seems like
they could be preparing us to see
spider-man in venom - I personally would
love this to happen and if it did happen
I would definitely freak out but let me
know what you think would you like to
see spider-man in venom to let me know
what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to give the video a
like and subscribe so you don't miss out
on anything relating to venom 2 for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]